يسأل الأمريكيون
من هاجم
بلدنا ، الأدلة التي جمعناها
جميعًا تشير إلى مجموعة من
المنظمات الإرهابية المرتبطة بشكل فضفاض
والمعروفة باسم القاعدة
بعد 20 عامًا من هجمات 9 11 ،
يمكن أن تبدو القاعدة وكأنها فكرة لاحقة أن
أسامة بن لادن مات منظمته 10 سنوات
تدهورت من خلال ضربات الطائرات بدون
طيار التي أهلكت طبقات متعددة
من قيادتها الضعيفة بن لادن
اختفى أيمن الوزواهري من المشهد
يعتقد البعض أنه في حالة صحية سيئة أو حتى
ميت ، وبالطبع لم يكن هناك
هجوم إرهابي محلي عن بعد على
مقياس 9 11 منذ
عام 2001. هذه علامات النجاح في
الحرب الخبيثة على الإرهاب ، إنها
شهادة على أجهزة
إنفاذ القانون والاستخبارات العسكرية الأمريكية
التي تم إيقاف العديد من المؤامرات الإرهابية
قبل وقوعها بما في ذلك
محاولات تفجير جسور الطائرات
وفي الحقيقة ،
تم توجيه تهم إلى 480 إرهابيًا محتملاً منذ 11 سبتمبر وفقًا
لمؤسسة أمريكا الجديدة
لكن في ظل كل هذا ، فإن خطر
الجهاد لم ينته بعد ، فقد
طغى آخرون على تقديم شبكة أكثر
لامركزية تحفز الذئاب المنفردة من
خلال التطرف عبر الإنترنت
مما أدى إلى هجمات إرهابية مميتة على
مدى العقد الماضي بما في ذلك
مذبحة ملهى ليلي النبض التي أودت بحياة 49 شخصًا.
إطلاق النار عام 2015 في سان برناردينو الذي
أسفر عن مقتل 14 شخصًا ،
ولكن تم ربط فرع واحد فقط للقاعدة
بهجوم محلي ، حيث
قتل عام 2019 ثلاثة أشخاص على يد مواطن سعودي
في قاعدة بحرية أمريكية في فلوريدا ،
على الرغم من أن حليف القاعدة
منذ فترة طويلة.  عودة طالبان
للسيطرة على أفغانستان هي علامة سيئة
، فقد كان هناك الكثير من الحديث البوليانياني
حول كيف سيكونون أكثر براغماتية هذه
المرة ،
لا تشتريها ،
وعد طالبان الرئيس ترامب بعدم
التعاون مع الجماعات أو الأفراد الذين
يهددون أمنهم.  تحذير
الولايات المتحدة وحلفائها
المفسد الذي لم
يكن أفضل بكثير هو ادعاء الرئيس بايدن
بأن القاعدة ذهبت من
الأفغاني.  البنتاغون الخاص به أكد
أن الأمر ليس كذلك وليس الأمر كما لو أن
هذا سر كبير حذر تقرير في يونيو من
الأمم المتحدة من أن
طالبان لا يزال على اتصال وثيق مع
القاعدة واعتبارًا من هذا الأسبوع عضوان
من طالبان المؤقتة.
مجلس الوزراء أعضاء في شبكة حقاني القاتلة التي
تربطها علاقات راسخة
بالقاعدة في الواقع ، أحدهم موجود بالفعل على
قائمة المطلوبين لدى مكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي ، حيث يشير
بيتر بيرغن ، محلل الأمن القومي في CNN ،
إلى عدم وجود شيء يقول إنك تتخلى عن
القاعدة تمامًا مثل تعيين عضو في
القاعدة.  إلى منصب وزاري أعلى في
حكومتك الجديدة
، يرى العديد من الجهاديين عبر شبكاتهم المترامية الأطراف والمتنافسة أحيانًا ، ولا شك
أن عودة طالبان إلى الظهور هي علامة على
أنه ينبغي تشجيعهم بعد 20 عامًا
من 9 11.
الانسحاب من أفغانستان لا
يعني أن الحرب الإرهابية علينا
انتهى الأمر ، للأسف ، دائمًا ما يكون
يومًا سيئًا بعيدًا عن كونه القضية رقم
واحد وربما لهذا السبب
أعاد الرئيس بايدن التفويض بهدوء  د إعلان الطوارئ الوطني الذي تم
وضعه بعد
11 سبتمبر بالأمس فقط
ولكن لا شيء من هذا يعني أن الأمريكيين
يجب أن يعيشوا في خوف وهذا بالطبع
ما يريدنا الإرهابيون أن
نفعله والآن يجب أن تكون لدينا الثقة
لنعرف أنه يمكننا مكافحة هذا التهديد
دون المساومة على قيمنا الأساسية أو
الانجراف إلى إغراءات الإمبراطورية
لأنه في العشرين عامًا منذ 9 11 ، قمنا
بإعادة بناء مانهاتن السفلى مرة أخرى
أكبر وأجمل مما كانت عليه أثناء
تقديم الإرهابيين الذين
هاجمونا القاعدة إلى العدالة بطريقة أو بأخرى
إن
التزامنا بسيادة القانون
وأسلوب الحياة الأمريكي هو
التوبيخ النهائي لأهدافهم البغيضة وعلى
كل الأخطاء التي ارتكبناها ، فإن أمريكا لا
تزال أرض الأحرار لأننا
موطن  شجاع وهذا هو
التحقق من الواقع الخاص بك